la maison des notaires
au début du 19e siècle saint denis est
le principal port de la colonie la
partie basse de la ville concentre les
entrepôts destiné à stocker les
marchandises venues d'europe et d'asie
débarqué sur le front de mer à proximité
de l'hôtel de la préfecture
elles sont acheminées vers ses entrepôts
construit par la compagnie des indes ce
quartier à vocation commerciale ont
également des commerces de gros et de
détail
de nombreuses entreprises reconverti
abrite à présent des services publics ou
des entreprises privées comme celui
aujourd'hui connu sous le nom de maison
du notaire le rez-de-chaussée servant
autrefois d'entrepôts est en basalte
tailler tandis que laitages alors habité
par les familles de commerçants est en
bois aujourd'hui 11 ans sa haute toiture
à quatre pans percée de lucarnes était à
l'origine en bardeaux la façade sur cour
contraste fortement avec la grande
austérité de celle donnant sur la rue
probablement ajoutés au début du 19e
siècle
elle est particulièrement raffiné hi-rez
part d un poste en bois découpé de
végétaux stylisés sa longue varangue est
fermé depuis les années 1930 par
déléguant de menuiserie à petit bois
devenu un office notarial au début du
20e siècle cet édifice est protégé au
titre des monuments historiques depuis
1996 c'est à cette occasion qu'il a été
baptisé maison des notaires bien qu'il
abrite à présent une agence bancaire